mercedes is in summerlin right now
getting ready to celebrate
at america's birthday party parade this
weekend how you doing mercedes
hey you guys it's a party in the usa
here we are so excited because yes it is
back this year we are talking about
america's birthday party
put on by the summerlin council and we
are ready to have some fun
this third of july actually let us
explain i have tommy pirello here and
you are going to tell us a little bit
about
what is happening this year tell us
this year's parade is a little bit
different um we had a shorter planning
period
based on the way the guidelines have
changed but we are so excited to be able
to
offer and grow a birthday party here in
summerlin with the help of our sponsors
and the community
it is 25 entries that start it's at
9 00 a.m so everyone needs to be in
place early so that they don't miss
out on the fun the route is also a
little bit shorter
so it will end at trail center which is
at the very beginning of the shopping
center
instead of at the far end of the
shopping center that people may have
come out and been there before yeah if
you've been to the patriotic parade
before you know it goes longer this is
shorter this is america's birthday party
celebration
and let's see kind of what we have going
on it's a party
like i said we're celebrating and we're
happy that it is back in person
but like tommy said this is actually
happening on saturday
the third of july not the fourth of july
so we want people to know that
and you need to get here early because
this is a more
abbreviated version of the parade this
year what kind of
what kind of floats what kind of talent
are we going to have this year
even though it's smaller scale we'll
still have all the pageantry the the
large floats
the helium balloons performance groups
that
people have seen before in the parade a
very exciting high energy
performance based uh show a mobile show
that wherever you are along the route
you'll be able to enjoy and and
celebrate with your friends and family
and community
yeah you want to make sure you get here
on time get your spot and we are so
excited because
again this year we are hosting it is
myself it is jc
it is also brian loftus and sheri swens
we all get to be a part of it but
instead of sitting in the grandstands
this year and calling the parade
we're actually in the parade so you're
going to see us in some of these floats
we're going to have a lot of fun there's
going to be so many great people like
the drum bots are going to be a part of
it the west las vegas arts center
that we'll have danzal carrizo the
native american dancers the swingit
girls
so much more so join us this
saturday july 3rd up by the trails
community center in summerland and we
have a party in the usa
absolutely please come join us we'll see
you guys then and send it back to you
hey mercedes i want to see right now
your best disney princess wave
you're getting ready you and jc both oh
here oh oh yeah
yeah let's see we're good high five
high five
you